foreign  [Music]  [Music]  to invite the people from different  places or the world to come to our  imagines to invite them to to talk with  the Qatari peoples and enjoy and  drinking tea and coffees and also to see  the house Qatari people's culture  foreign  [Music]  people they are very generous and and  they opened their doors and they are  hard to talk with everyone  this is a normal things in Qatar  everybody in Qatar they have in their  house they have a message institution  place like this is always bothering  because it talks really to the heart and  the soul that you know the Qatari  culture or the agriculture still exists  thank you  [Applause]